Harvie when you get a call from someone
to take on a project or to consider a
project what are some of the first
things you do to make sure that you want
to commit to it first of all I look and
see if I have kind of the bandwidth to
do it scheduling and it's something I
can fit into my workload and then more
importantly I look at it from the
standpoint of is it something that's
gonna be really really good really
really high quality something that I'm
gonna have fun doing something that is
not gonna be like coming to the studio
every day like oh yeah what am i working
on I just this point in my career I want
to do great things I want to do projects
that I'm really proud of and do things
that I enjoy enjoy creating well
definitely was sing I can say I can see
why you would want to do that project
thing was a no-brainer for me because it
was so much great music it was working
with an amazing cast and one of my
favorite directors and kind of studio
head combinations I've ever worked with
with Chris Miller Dondre and Garth
Jennings those guys were just amazing I
always loved working with Michael block
at Universal because he's a real musical
guy and so when he calls me with a
project usually it's it's something
exciting because it has so much music
he's really intense about music and he
loves it and so again when he calls and
said hey I got a potential project I
usually stop what I'm doing and really
really concentrate on what he's talking
about because it's usually something fun
and straight out of Compton I did for
him the James Brown film get on up I did
for him so just you know real music
intensive projects and I know in another
interview with Jennifer Hudson you too
talked about how some of the music is
much older and a lot of generations even
Millennials may not know some of these
artists unfortunately so I think it's
great that you're bringing yeah that's
really been my kind of goal with some of
those music is to freshen it up a little
bit so that young people can enjoy it
and listen to it and maybe that will
make them go back and listen to some of
the stuff that that artist had done
before
and it introduces it to them in a way
they can digest it I think right going
back to something you said earlier about
wanting to enjoy what you're working on
I know you're at a point in your career
where you can probably be choosy which
is probably an excellent place to be but
what is it about a project or how do you
decide that you know what I think maybe
this won't be for me and was it always
that way for you were you always at a
place where you thought I don't want to
work on it because I'm not going to be
committed 100% no I wasn't always at
that place because I used to commit to
everything 100% and then got really
draining and tiring and it taxed my
creativity you know for years and years
and years we were doing records and
artists that were not great artists or
artists that you might not think would
come out and a lot of them didn't come
out a lot of it were we wasted a lot of
really good material good songs on
artists that we probably shouldn't have
been working on but early stages in my
career I just wanted to create I wanted
to be in the studio I wanted to be
working and I wanted to perfect my craft
so I used a lot of years doing things
that I otherwise wouldn't have done but
I think it all is a progression it goes
in stages and one thing leads to another
and gets me to where I am I worked with
artists that were new and and I didn't
know they would come out but it ended up
I worked with one of them being Chris
Brown who was 14 years old when I
started with them and at that time we
were doing a ton of artists for jive
records a lot of them were new or
unsigned and you never know what's gonna
hit what's not gonna hit and he ended up
being kind of a career artist for me and
somebody I've done the you know tons of
songs with so early in my career I
definitely took approach the approach of
work with everybody give it your all
pour everything you have into every
project now as you said I'm a little bit
more selective and I really try and
concentrate on stuff that I think is
going to be great well I think you
started out with jingles in the
beginning they did and would you say to
let's suppose someone new starting out
whether it's in music producing or film
acting whatever take on every project
you can at first but then once you get
to a certain level choose which ones are
actually gonna fulfill you instead of
drain you absolutely and I would say
take on every pride no project is too
small
can learn from every project you can
improve from every project you can also
build your name and reputation with
every project early on in your career I
would recommend anyone in the arts you
know acting or creating anything I would
say start with doing everything you can
get your hands on any project because
you can always improve you can always
get better you can always build your
reputation and build your name you don't
know who's gonna hear that song that you
wrote for that horrible artist and then
it leads you to a great artist and also
you don't know what you're gonna pick up
from any given session any given artist
you can learn one of the things that
last you an entire career I learned so
many things early in my in my studio
sessions that have stayed with me
forever and all the way to this point
where I do what I do now I love what I
do now I learned really early in my
career so that's a formative time in
your creative process early on and I
don't think at that point you can afford
to be choosy I see a lot of people doing
that and I go I'm not gonna work on that
I'm not gonna work on that and I think
that's a huge mistake I think you do
everything you can because there's
always some little kind of tiny nugget
you're gonna get from every day you show
up to work in the studio and it's like
repetitions you have to do it and you
have to do hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of songs to get to that place
where you're creating great ones
you